so I really want to spend some time
today talking about what is now at first
we suspected it but it's now very clear
is the real possibility of violence I'm
talking about physical violence if
Donald Trump were to lose in November
and this is I don't really want to make
this about Trump because it's not this
really ties together sort of the faux
populist rhetoric that I've been warning
about it ties together Fox News in the
propaganda space and in order to talk
about this today we're gonna look at a
clip from Tucker Carlson's program on
Monday I believe it was on Monday night
and what I want you to consider here is
not just the growing influence of Tucker
Carlson and in fact there are people now
talking about what about Tucker for
president in 2024 if Trump can be
President certainly at least
theoretically Tucker Carlson could be
President of the United States and I
know that that will be very very scary
to many of you but I also want to use
the clips we're going to look at today
as a sort of case study in how the media
propaganda cycle works and how it will
completely reverse reality and take
advantage of the lack of education and
critical thinking skills that are part
of what got Donald Trump elected in the
first place so Tucker Carlson is no
longer playing coy he is straight up
saying the left is dangerous the left
hates America and the left is a
fundamental threat to the way of life
that Tucker
I guess espouses through his faux
populist rhetoric Tucker Carlson in
doing this is setting the stage for
violence if Donald Trump loses he's both
planting the seed of the idea in the
minds of right-wingers and he's giving
right-wingers justification for doing
violence if Joe Biden were to get
elected in November and the the sort of
crux of it is the left hates America the
left despises this country and we're
going to look at a segment it was a
15-minute segment we're going to look at
some different pieces of it and after
opening up this segment by talking about
how the Left only hates Trump because
they
control him not because he's incompetent
not because he's actively damaging the
United States every single day Tucker
says the left just hates Trump because
they can't control him he's a free
thinker he's an independent mind he
starts to weave us through this left
hates America idea by saying it starts
in school school kids aren't taught the
history of Mount Rushmore and Thomas
Jefferson that Donald Trump talked about
at his July 3rd Mount Rushmore speech
and they're not taught about how the
u.s. is a force for good that defeated
fascism and communism it starts in
school Tucker Carlson says take a look
yet as the president pointed out
American school children learn virtually
none of this instead our curricula have
become a toxic mix of lies in omission
all of it designed to poison our
children against the country that formed
them against every law of society in
nature our children are taught in school
to hate their own country and to believe
that the men and women who built it
we're not heroes but that were villains
the radical view of American history is
a web of lies all perspective is removed
every virtue is obscured every motive is
twisted every fact is distorted and
every flaw is magnified until the
history is purged and the record is
disfigured beyond all recognition every
word of that is true if you have kids in
school you know it may even be
understatement what is happening in our
classrooms right now in 2020 is a crime
it is long past time that a sitting
president said so so why am i starting
with the stuff about schools why is
Tucker starting with the stuff about
schools this is how you start priming
the right towards violence our schools
have been taken over by liberal lies and
liberal liars Trump is saying it and
Tucker is willing to say it and that's
the framework for what is going to come
now the reason
this is so pernicious is that our
schools are failing it is true that much
of our education system is not working
but it's failing as evidenced by Trump
being elected in other words it's
failing as evidenced by 60 plus million
people falling for the obviously false
talking points of the Trump campaign in
2015 and 2016 and voting for him so
there's a big problem with our schools
but the problem isn't our kids are being
taught what what I guess Tucker and
Trump say is some incorrect version of
history our schools are failing and that
American students are falling further
and further behind behind in math and
science compared to many other countries
our schools are failing in that critical
thinking and civics and media literacy
are all but gone unless you're like
really lucky or seek them out at some
narrow slice of the School of Public
Schools and because of that sixty
million americans voted for Donald Trump
but people fall for stuff like we have
15 cases of coronavirus which will soon
be zero right that that's the evidence
that education is failing people fall
for these bogus tax cuts that are really
you get a little more money in your
paycheck but your refund is smaller at
the end of the year millions of people
fell for that so this is how Tucker lays
the groundwork schools cannot be trusted
in schools are ruining our kids and
turning them against our country now we
go to the next part of this monologue
skipping ahead a couple of minutes
Tucker starts ginning up the hatred with
dog whistles starts up again with the
violent protests check out how he
transitions here if you spent the rest
of your life trying to locate to
identify the worst people in this
country of 330 million you couldn't get
a pure distillation than what you just
saw these people are liars they're the
same people who spent the last month
telling you that the riots you saw live
on television were actually peaceful
protests against racism that was a lie
they knew it was a lie when they said it
but they said it anyway in order to
undermine a country that they hate yes
hey America deserves
to be in flames that is their view and
this weekend they said it essentially
out loud no one said that riots and
looting were peaceful protesting what we
said was which is true we had
overwhelmingly peaceful protests against
police brutality and in addition to that
there were some looters and there were
some rioters and I can only speak for
myself but I didn't say that that was
evidence of peaceful protesting the
peaceful protesting was peaceful
protesting the other stuff was other
things but now you see the big picture
the narrative that Tucker Carlson is
weaving and I admit it he does it well
these are well scripted monologues where
listen schools are teaching kids to hate
America that was part one then those
kids become left-wing rioters who go out
and destroy our cities because they've
been taught to hate America so he's
building up the justification for
violence if Donald Trump were to lose
and then he goes fully into it the left
hates America that is the next part of
the message and if Tucker convinces his
audience that the left hates America
violence against the left in their eyes
would be justified because it would be
protecting America and that's where
Tucker keeps going and comes full circle
now with Joe Biden this is a clever
monologue this is you know because a lot
of the people who watch these programs
lack the basic critical thinking and
epistemology skills and media literacy
skills this is a far more clever
monologue than most of Tucker's viewers
are going to be able to pick apart for
what it is you start with our schools
teach kids to hate which has led the
left to hate America and go and riot and
then that same left who hates America
wants to elect Joe Biden and that's how
he links it all together to Joe Biden
and lays the groundwork for violence if
Biden wins take a look so where's Joe
Biden on all of this as the revolution
continues apace Biden is supposed to be
a moderate remember that was his chief
appeal but there was nothing moderate
about Biden's fourth of July statement
instead it was a full-throated attack on
the United States our country was
founded on an idea
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
I've never lived up to it Jefferson
himself did he held slaves women were
excluded American history is no fairy
tale it's been a constant push and pull
between
two parts of our character the idea that
all men and women all people are created
equal and the racism that has torn us
apart we have a chance to rip the roots
of systemic racism out of this country
that's your fourth of July message
systemic racism something you can't even
define that has no real definition
really wagging your finger in the face
of the nation that promoted someone is
mediocre as you to the position you
currently hold this is the man who could
soon be our figurehead so now you've
seen the full path the left hates our
country because schools are teaching
them to after learning to hate the
country they go out and attack the
country by rioting and looting and then
they will support Joe Biden who is
supportive of that America hatred and
rioting and looting he's suggesting the
imagery of a Joe Biden presidency as a
presidency equivalent to tantamount to
hating America and rioting and looting
and then on the tail end
Tucker wraps it up with this sort of
faux modest statement of you know on
this program we really try not to
question people's patriotism because
that's a really serious thing to do but
we have to because clearly these people
hate the country take a look at that so
what a make of all of this well it's
long been considered out of bounds to
question a person's patriotism it's a
very strong charge and we try not ever
to make it but in the face of all of
this the conclusion can't be avoided
these people actually hate America
there's no longer a question about that
and yet paradoxically at the same time
they desperately want to control America
more than anything and that leads to the
most basic of all questions can you
really lead a country that you hate ask
yourself what kind of parent would you
be if you hated your children what kind
of officer would you make if you didn't
care about your troops it would be awful
the results would be ugly it would not
work loving the people you lead carrying
deep
about them is the most basic
prerequisite of leadership the leaders
of today's democratic party do not they
despise this country they have said so
they continue to that is shocking but it
is also disqualifying we cannot let them
run this nation because they hate it
imagine what they would do to it they
hate America is the fundamental message
so the right is falling for this hook
line and sinker and it is so unhinged
that it actually could bring the right
to violence if Joe Biden wins if you
believe Tucker about this if you sit
there for the thirteen and a half
minutes or however long it is and you
not along and you say yeah schools are
teaching hid kids to become protesters
who riot and then elect Joe Biden if
Trump loses on November 3rd and you
believe that you might feel justified in
going out with your guns to try to put a
stop to this America hatred from the
left and this gets us back to something
that I've now had to bring up three or
four times which is the populist
rhetoric bamboozles people when I talked
a few six weeks ago maybe about how I'm
worried that left populist rhetoric may
be replacing the actual set of ideas
that is social democracy the main
concern was the rhetoric sounds pretty
damn good and it's very similar rhetoric
from left to right when it comes to
populism the middle class is the core of
this country and we need to support the
average person and all of this different
stuff this is exactly what I'm talking
about because then they slip in the
prescription which is no leftists
conservative school agendas no
immigrants black lives matter will take
your house the prescription is
absolutely bonkers and notice that
Tucker doesn't talk about policy and
when Tucker bragged in the monologue I
don't know if I played it but it was in
the monologue Tucker said Trump's speech
at Mount Rushmore was one of the best of
his presidency Tucker said you'll notice
that that speech at Mount Rushmore had
essentially no policy ideas it was Trump
railing against Marxists who
exist there's no prominent Marxist that
Trump is reasonably fighting against he
railed against anarchists on the Left he
railed against people who teach our kids
to hate America there were no lists
there was no list of accomplishments of
what Trump did other than you know lies
about defeating the virus which we
clearly haven't done and there was no
sort of a guidebook for what you would
get policy wise from Trump in his second
term this is the epitome of being
bamboozled by populist rhetoric no
policy and Tucker says that was a great
speech Trump really laid it out all
Trump laid out is an imaginary enemy a
straw man from the left of these violent
Marxist anarchists which don't exist and
then Trump then has the benefit of
Tucker going to his audience and saying
that was a great speech it was an
amazingly good speech that Donald Trump
gave all Trump said is the left is
radical and hates everybody in blah blah
blah and respect our heritage again
another illusion to Confederate statues
in the Confederate flag so this is
extremely dangerous and it's
particularly dangerous for two reasons
one I I don't I'm not trying to insult
people when I say this but the lack of
critical thinking and and media literacy
skills in this country makes this stuff
really effective that monologue already
has like a million and a half views on
YouTube and there are people on the
right and even some on the left who are
getting tricked into sharing this Tucker
Carlson stuff so we've got to do
something about it I don't even know
what it is because the audience that he
is catering to with this garbage is ripe
for it they're not going to then come
and watch me spend 15 minutes explaining
to you how you're being bamboozled by
this so I if I don't sound optimistic
it's because I'm not I don't know what
the solution is and it's extraordinarily
dangerous what's going on I want to hear
your thoughts about it I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman remember that you can get the
full audio podcast of the show every day
on whatever your favorite podcasting
platform is be it Spotify or Pandora or
iTunes or Google Play it's free get the
daily podcast and the next Tuesday two
big things
on Tuesday number one the third david
pakman show chess tournament at 8:00
p.m. Eastern on Tuesday you can register
for free at david pakman.com slash chess
and then number two we took a big hit on
memberships in the last week we're
trying to dig out from a hole of like
300 cancellations so Tuesday the same
day as the chess tournament we're going
to do a one-day membership special where
we will email out to everybody on our
mailing list a very exclusive one-day
discount code buy exclusive it just
means you've got to be getting our
newsletter you can sign up to be
notified on david pakman.com upper right
of the website type in your email
address sign up for the newsletter you
will be notified very powerfully on
Tuesday and then I hope you'll join us
for the chess tournament as well the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are robin nye and
javier palau thanks to robin and javier
for the memberships and for the support
you can join them at join pakman.com and
if you stick around long enough you
might be the all time I'm sorry longtime
sustaining member of the day some day in
the future today's long time sustainer
is Kelly Lindsay who's been a david
pakman show member for almost 5 years
incredible so we've been tracking the
rise of coronavirus cases in the united
states and we started seeing the numbers
spike on june 19th there was the idea in
late April early May that that was the
peak when we had 30,000 new cases a day
in April May we were hoping I guess I
mean I certainly was hoping that we were
past the peak at least the wave one peak
and it looked like maybe we were until
July June 19th when we started seeing
cases climb and climb and climb up to as
many as 60,000 new cases a day a few
days ago centered around California and
a bunch of red states including Arizona
Florida and Texas at the top of that
list and what we observed for the last
20 or so days was that even though the
cases were spiking the deaths were
staying pretty low and you can see if
you're looking that at the chart of
deaths
they've been trending down and all along
there were questions about how is this
possible what's going on now the most
obvious explanation maybe we would call
it the simplest explanation we could say
the explanation that requires the fewest
assumptions is that there's simply a lag
between cases and deaths
you don't die the day you're diagnosed
so when you see cases spike you would
expect that it would take some time
before those increased case numbers turn
into deaths there were other
explanations that we considered as well
is it possible that the virus has
mutated to be less deadly it's possible
we didn't have any evidence for it is it
possible that doctors are getting better
at treating coronavirus patients which
is decreasing the death rate certainly
possible could it be that more testing
means healthier people are getting
tested so even though you have more
cases the share of cases that are
serious could be declining and that's
why the deaths continue to trend down or
is it younger people getting coronavirus
who are less likely to get really sick
all of these are reasonable
possibilities to wonder about but if the
explanation is the first one which is
there's a lag between cases and deaths
we would expect that somewhere in the
range of 18 to 21 days after the cases
spike deaths would start to spike 18 to
21 days from the start of the case spike
is this week it's yesterday it's today
it's tomorrow and sadly tragically
yesterday Arizona and Texas both hit
single day death records dating all the
way back to the start of the pandemic
yesterday we had again nearly 60,000 new
cases of corona virus reported and
deaths in Arizona and Texas and by the
way also in California California is not
exempt from this but it's been mostly
the red state are saying that it's
Arizona and Texas that weren't going to
see the death spike they are spiking
Arizona with a hundred and seventeen
deaths yesterday Texas with eighty four
deaths yesterday those are sad these are
not records we want to be setting these
are tragic new high marks for
coronavirus deaths in a single day now I
don't want to be alarmist and I hope
that I'm wrong and I believe that I've
been relatively sober in my analysis of
coronavirus from the start the simplest
explanation is that the deaths are
spiking because the cases spiked 20 days
ago
and if that's the case in another 10
days the death numbers are going to look
really really bad and what I mean by
that is cases started to spike on June
19 so the small spike in deaths were
seeing now would be related to the start
of the spike in cases on June 19th
around July 1st the new case numbers
were dramatically higher than on June
19th and if that tracks as a leading
indicator to eventual deaths in another
10 or 15 days we are going to have
unconscionable numbers coming out of
some of these states it's horrible when
we're right about terrible things and
this is really really terrible now if we
want to find something to look at that
looks ok there are still some states
doing quite well right now the states
with the lowest reproduction rate of the
virus are Connecticut Washington DC
which is not a state Maine New Hampshire
Massachusetts Rhode Island Maryland and
Utah although the reproduction rate
there what's called the Arnott or the r0
it's it's starting to creep up and what
I believe is going on is nothing that
requires any kind of particular insight
the states that are doing well can only
hold off cases for so long if other
states are a disaster because travel
between states is constitutionally is
it's a constitutional right in the
United States ingress and egress from in
two states and when you look at the
county level map of the United States
and you see you know the red and orange
counties the ones that are in trouble
they're right next to counties that are
doing far better and so I believe that
sadly unless there are some interstate
travel restrictions put in place which
I'm neither recommending nor do I
believe would necessarily be legal and
merely making a sort of mathematical
statement you're going to see some of
the states that are doing well start to
do less well if cases continue to
skyrocket in places like Florida Arizona
California Texas and many others I can't
even give you the full list now I I do
think also that there are some
governor's including our governor here I
believe Charlie Baker here in
Massachusetts has widely done of
good job and what I'm worried about is
they're now doing the indoor dining in
Massachusetts I got a message from my
gym that it's opening next Monday I
think that this is a mistake we've done
so much work here for the last four
months to get down to only having a
couple hundred new cases a day without a
spike it's like everyday about 200 cases
200 cases it seems to me given that it's
summer given that people can do outdoor
dining given that people can do outdoor
workouts I understand the business side
of it it seems too risky to me to do
indoor dining or to open gyms movie
theaters and some of the other things
being discussed I won't be partaking
I've been doing the outdoor dining it
feels safe it's more than enough it's
warm out I think that that's a risk for
the states that are doing well to do
right now and I hope that I'm wrong but
the numbers are truly truly scary so I
want to talk a little bit about PPP
funds you know when these programs were
put in place I could have gone out and
gotten PPP money to pay employees and to
pay studio rent even though we're not
using the studio right now we're still
paying rent for it because we have a
lease but when this opportunity was
presented to me I kind of thought it
through and I realized we are getting
hit because of the virus a lot of people
are canceling memberships we're having
some advertisers drop out YouTube
revenue is down but we're not really
that affected like if I was a restaurant
that was closed my revenue has just gone
to zero so I decided there's limited
money I'm not gonna take this this
funding I'm not going to do it I'm gonna
leave the money for somebody else I
opted out and some people in our
audience grabbed some memberships and
made up for a little bit of the hole we
were digging out of we've now learned
because the data has been released about
who received large amounts of money
through this government bailout program
that Kanye West's clothing line has been
bailed out Scientology the Church of
Scientology took money Kanye West's
clothing line was cleared to receive
five million dollars this is a billion
dollar brand they received five million
dollars the Church of Scientology
which is so so wealthy and a major
holder of real estate and I want to
remind people that these were loans
designed in a way where as long as the
loans are used with certain parameters
like to pay for payroll etc you don't
need to repay the money so this these
were loans that are largely forgivable
if you use the money in the prescribed
ways so for churches and other entities
that don't pay taxes they aren't paying
taxes which is ultimately where this
money comes from right as money's coming
from government revenues the taxes I pay
the taxes you pay and they are taking
that money American citizen money and
then they are receiving it and they're
never going to have to pay it back and
the example I mean there's so many
examples I could spend all day just
giving you examples the Soho House which
is a membership club controlled by a
billionaire named Ron Burkle
they got loans between nine and twenty
three million dollars they applied for a
bunch of loans they have different
locations in Miami Beach in Chicago and
New York etc more than 400 country clubs
and golf resorts got PPP money the ein
Rand Institute which is all about Iran's
philosophy about self-sufficiency and
not depending on governments the ein
Rand Institute who we've done work with
we've we've interviewed people from the
ioan Rand Institute and I've moderated
some debates they took money remember
I'm Rand was against depending on
government but received welfare benefits
the I Rand Institute which espouses her
ideology also got PPP bailout money so
there's a few different things here
number one this is why we need oversight
and this is why they didn't want
oversight it yeah all the billionaire
developer Joe Farrell who builds mega
mansions in the Hamptons got a PPP loan
of somewhere up to a million dollars
private jet companies which have quickly
rebounded because rich people now
instead of flying first class or
chartering a private jet they're
increasingly buying private jets or
private jet companies are buying more
jets in order to allow rich people to
charter them so they very quickly
recovered private jet companies got PPP
money
jet links aviation it's an insanely long
list but meanwhile all these small
businesses have failed
restaurant owners I know in eastern
Massachusetts and in western
Massachusetts and even in other parts of
the country they're just closing there
they're done they're not coming back
again again I could have taken some PPP
cash to pay employees and cover studio
rent but because I decided you know
we're not that bad off we're not that
port we're not we're not that poorly
positioned I can just kind of go to my
audience and say listen a lot of people
had to cancel maybe you can get a $6 a
month membership like that was my ask
because I wanted to do what I thought
was the right thing so it's very
disturbing to see the way that this has
gone down of course a lot of you know
it's crony capitalism a lot of Trump's
friends have gotten huge huge money but
there's also the irony that the same
people who say we shouldn't be dependent
on government are actually the first in
line for the handouts and a lot of them
are wealthy conservatives every broke
and struggling small business owner
should be furious about what's going in
going on and you know the the right
loves to claim to be against socialism
but they're against it as long as it's
not helping poor people right when when
it's not rather when it's not helping
poor people that was confusing when it's
not helping poor people when it's
helping them and their friends all of a
sudden socialism is ok and last point on
this if you know how they always say
well private companies are gonna do
better jobs at things than the
government if a private company had
screwed up the distribution of PPP funds
this badly heads would be rolling people
would be fired there would be massive
penalties and meanwhile the Trump
administration is essentially getting a
pass using with no oversight PPP money
being used as a slush fund for Trump's
friends and other people in positions of
power it's you know it's infuriating but
it's also just really sad and depressing
that this is did we really expect
anything else when Donald Trump when
Trump talks about doing infrastructure
spending he talks about doing it by
handing out contracts to his buddies you
know
there's always some crony capitalist
background to this and we're going to
continue covering this over on our
Instagram page at david pakman show so
make sure you're following us there
we're going to take a quick break I am
going to talk about meri Trump's book
coming up next the david pakman show at
david pakman.com the David Pakman show
depends on the support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through patreon where you can
pledge as little as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash David Pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him welcome
back to the David Pakman show so Donald
Trump's estranged niece Marielle Trump
has been working on a book which is set
to be published next week after having
the publishing date moved up the book is
called too much and never enough how my
family created the world's worst the
world's most dangerous man so I want to
talk about this because there's really a
lot going on here first of all marry
Trump is the daughter of Trump's brother
Fred Trump jr.
Fred Trump jr. is the brother who died
in 1981 he was 42 at the time of a heart
attack caused by alcoholism this is told
as the story as the reason why Trump
doesn't drink or smoke cigarettes the
book was scheduled to be published
further down the line but it was moved
up to be expected to be published next
week there are a bunch of claims made
about Donald Trump in the book there
have been attempts from Trump's family
including Trump's brother to stop the
publication of the book and then there
are also the questions of whether
marielle Trump's claims can be believed
now Donald Trump's advisers and other
people around him have claimed that the
book is riddled with lies
as you may know if these lies are
actually lies there is legal recourse
which is called a libel lawsuit some of
the allegations include that Donald
Trump paid someone to take the SATs for
him when he was in high school which was
how he got into the University of
Pennsylvania specifically the claim is
that he paid a kid named Joe Shapiro to
take the SAT test for him the book
alleges that Donald Trump was verbally
abused by his father Fred Trump the book
actually says quote casual
dehumanization of people was commonplace
at the Trump dinner table both Trump and
his brother were supposedly abused by
their dad but Trump maybe was less
affected by it according to Mary L Trump
because he's a quote sociopaths marry
Trump claims that trumps dad viewed
apologizing as a sign of weakness that's
interesting because Donald Trump never
apologizes for anything she also says
that lying was a way of life in the
Trump household including as a way to
get around their dad disapproving of
what they were doing again Trump lies
all the time and seems to have no qualms
whatsoever she tells the story of where
Trump allegedly went to see a movie the
night that his brother was sent to the
hospital for that alcohol induced heart
attack that ultimately killed him in
1981 she claims Trump has been lying
about being religious obviously we knew
that one and she says Trump has never
actually gone to church other than when
there are cameras there I actually don't
care that Trump is not religious I did a
segment a couple of years ago about
whether Donald Trump is the first
atheist president I don't care that
Trump isn't religious what I care about
is the fact that he lies and panders by
pretending to be religious in order to
appeal to evangelical voters marry out
Trump who's also a clinical psychologist
believes she's observed in Donald Trump
all nine criteria for narcissistic
personality disorder we've gone through
that criteria that's also not hugely
shocking or groundbreaking she
mentions that he has essentially been
institutionalized for his entire adult
life and that he might not survive in
the so-called real world if he didn't
have a business created for him with
daddy's money and I've made the same
observation Donald Trump's behavior as
president of the United States never
mind as the guy running the Trump
Organization in the real world in a
normal job Trump would have been fired
Trump would have a real difficulty in
holding a job so that's not a
particularly shocking claim and marielle
Trump also believes that Donald Trump
has an undiagnosed learning disability
which prevents him from processing
information there are also claims that
Trump's sister Mary Ann Trump Barry
believes a lot of the same stuff
privately but has chosen not to say it
publicly so listen unbalanced I have to
tell you there isn't that much that's
newsworthy here or that is new really I
mean okay the claim about paying someone
to take his SATs it's new and it's very
specific being abused by his dad that's
a new claim but it's not surprising I
mean people who treat others like crap
often were treated the same way growing
up so when I look at Donald Trump and I
look at the bullying on social media I
look at Trump making fun I mean
everything right gold star families
disabled reporters criticizing Hispanic
people talking about [ __ ] country all
of this stuff I see a damaged person who
is repeating the same thing they were
exposed to these aren't excuses like he
still is a bad president and shouldn't
be president partially because of how he
treats others but it's not
groundbreaking to imagine that people
that treat others like crap were once
treated like crap themselves you know
the learning disability claim it's not
surprising we've talked about is Trump's
apparent lack of attention inability to
remember and retain stuff verbal
glitches you know all this different
stuff is there cognitive decline going
on
could it be frontotemporal dementia the
side effect of some medication drug
whatever right there's all these
different ideas learning disability
could also explain a lot of what we see
with Donald Trump it's a reasonable
speculation specifically it's new from
the book but it's not altogether
surprising so what for me what's most
interesting about the book is that based
on what we've observed of Donald Trump
for the last three-and-a-half years as
president and much longer insofar as
Trump has been a public figure it's not
surprising what is alleged there's
nothing in there where I would go wow
that's a really crazy claim that's way
out of left field
Trump cheats all the time and he
believes in buying his way to whatever
he needs so Trump paying someone to take
his SATs if indeed he did it it's not
really surprising the behavior we've
observed observed none of it is
surprising and the picture that's
painted by Marielle Trump's book is the
picture of an insecure man who lacks
knowledge and lacks cognitive capacity
but is extremely narcissistic and has
very low morals and so he's willing to
pay for what he needs to pay he's
willing to say whatever he thinks will
benefit hit at the benefit him at the
time it's a very coherent and consistent
picture of the Donald Trump that we know
we will ultimately see whether there are
any legal repercussions for what Trump
Associates are calling a book filled
with lies and that's what I want to talk
about next
so we already went through a lot of the
allegations made and Marielle Trump's
book about Donald Trump Trump was
verbally abused by his dad wouldn't be
surprising he treats people like crap
often people repeat what they grew up
around Trump paid someone to take his
SATs new claim but wouldn't be hugely
surprising Trump has a learning
disability it's a new take on Trump's
cognitive appearing cognitively
compromised would not be hugely
surprising Trump's not really religious
he only goes to church when there's a
camera there or it's advantageous and
some I mean like none of the claims were
very surprising but the people around
Donald Trump have reacted explosively to
the forthcoming publication of this book
first you have Trump advisor Kellyanne
Conway who just lost it on Fox News over
this book she acts
we threaten members of the media saying
quote I believe family matters should be
family matters which is that there's a
whole other story there where she and
her husband have been publicly tweeting
stuff related to their daughter but that
that's a different story
I believe family matters should be
family matters I think the thin-skinned
troubled living in a glass house
mainstream media members who think
people's families are their business
ought to really think thrice the next
time they do that sort of throwing in a
thinly veiled threat at the media there
is Kellyanne Conway of course you might
notice not actually refuting any of the
allegations that are made in meri
Trump's book then Trump press secretary
Kaley McKenna knee had a hilarious brief
statement about this saying I've not
seen the book and it's filled with lies
wait so you didn't see it but you know
what's in it listen very very carefully
here and this is going to be an
instructive moment for us
no response other than it's a book of
falsehoods and that's not it
self-aggrandizing offensive power
it's ridiculous absurd allegations that
have absolute no bearing and truth have
yet to see the book but it is a book of
falsehood alright thank you guys I have
yet to see the book but it's a book of
falsehoods so this is a great
opportunity to show you how this
administration tries to bully the media
and to foment the narrative of fake news
even when it doesn't exist the narrative
that reporters are biased is always the
priority for this administration Kaley
McKenna nee clearly said there I have
yet to see the book but it is a book of
falsehoods ABC reporter Jonathan Karl
quoted her verbatim tweeting quote press
secretary offers an interesting take on
the mary trump book i have yet to see
the book but it is a book of falsehoods
so that's Jonathan Karl quoting Kaley
mccannon II verbatim Kayla McKenna
Kaylee McKenna knee tweets in response
don't be disingenuous Jonathan Karl
though I don't possess a physical copy
of the fictitious book since I'm not in
the press corps my inbox has been
flooded with the false claims and
excerpts from the book you know how this
works
and yet here you are but again her claim
was not I've not seen a physical copy of
the book but I know what's in it and
it's filled with lies and here are the
specific lies her claim wasn't I haven't
seen the book but I know what's in it
and thus I'm able to intelligently
comment on her claim was only I haven't
seen the book and it's a book of
falsehoods and Jonathan Karl quoted her
verbatim but more importantly this is
how they turn the narrative on the
reporter if there are lies in the book
tell us which are the lies and as of
right now they have not substantively
refuted any of the claims all of the
claims are completely consistent with
everything we know about Donald Trump we
say it's a lie or Trump says it's a lie
is not really anything and it's
instructive in how they turn this
completely around and make it about the
reporter make it about the fake news
media when really I mean I I don't I
don't want to deflate the importance of
this book because it's a powerful book
to hear from someone's
that that was an insider to the Trump
family although she's now estranged but
nothing in the book is even that notable
because it's also in line with what
we've observed from Donald Trump and
when they come out and just say it's all
lies well is it because it all sounds
super consistent in the picture at
paints of an insecure narcissistic man
with delusions of grandeur willing to do
whatever he believes in the moment will
help him get ahead and that's really the
picture that we've that's the Donald
Trump we've known and that's exactly the
picture that's painted in the book and
so far no specific refutation of
anything that is in there we're gonna
take a break and coming up after the
break we are going to talk about a
Mississippi Election Commissioner who is
furious that quote the blacks plan to
vote yeah that's coming up next the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
so let's talk about just a crazy story
out of Mississippi a Mississippi
Election Commissioner was caught on
Facebook I guess caught I mean I don't
know if that's even the right word
posting on Facebook that the blacks are
registering to vote and that
Mississippians need to do something
about it it's sort of implying that the
blacks in Mississippi aren't really the
Mississippians obviously this woman who
did this is white now for context
Mississippi is a state in trouble if you
look at American states ranked by Human
Development Index which is a sort of
composite statistic of life expectancy
education and per capita income
Mississippi is dead last if you look at
health care rankings Mississippi is dead
last or sometimes 48th or 49th if you
look at education rankings Mississippi
is 46th though so Mississippi is a place
with some serious problems black folks
make up a large percentage of the
Mississippi population and good for them
they're registering to vote
they're holding voter registration
drives they plan to vote so that they
can help their state improve in other
words you don't vote to ruin your state
you vote to improve your state by having
a say in what it is that who is going to
lead you and what it is that they're
going to do Jones County Election
Commissioner Gayle Harrison Welch posted
on Facebook that she's concerned that
lots of the blacks are registering to
vote that's it that's her concern
there's no caveat she says quote I'm
election so that I'm reading it as she
wrote it I'm a election commissioner in
Jones County I'm concerned about voter
registration in Mississippi the blacks
are having lots of events for voter
registration people in Mississippi have
to get involved too thank you for all
you do by the way before we get out this
this is super funny a guy named John
Welch who shares her last name and
appears to be a family member responded
to her Facebook comment by saying quote
Gail you are no longer welcome at family
reunions about 60 years ago all parts of
the
family faced a choice racism or
Americanism the Virginia side of the
Welch family from the Shenandoah chose
America you are plainly wrong which is
absolutely hilarious to see her family's
dirty laundry aired on Facebook but
eventually because this was a public
post on Facebook she was confronted
about her statement by the local
newspaper the Clarion Ledger and she
said quote I don't mean anything by it
I've worked hard to make sure everybody
is registered to vote black or white
everybody that's just how I am now in my
experience most people who refer to the
blacks doing something do mean something
by it that is racially tinged if not
straight-up racist and also when she
says the blacks are having lots of
events to register voters people in
Mississippi have to get involved too it
is obviously implying that she sees
black Mississippians as not really the
people of Mississippi it's the white
people in Mississippi that are really
the people of Mississippi now her other
excuse and this is crazy because it's
not an excuse her other excuse was the
message was meant to be sent as a
private message on Facebook it wasn't
meant to be public I hate to break it to
you all that means is you had the sense
to realize it shouldn't be public it
should be private in order to avoid more
scrutiny but it doesn't make it any less
racist or any more outrageous and the
real tragedy and this is the the sort of
circling around the real tragedy is she
still has this position in Jones County
in Mississippi she said this in a state
that is more than 30 percent black and
she is still an election official in
Jones County Mississippi at least as of
this morning and if that changes I
certainly let you know but this is you
know it the right has this idea that
calling someone racist is the worst
thing you can do and they've actually
weaponized claims of racism against
those who make the claims you see this
very frequently where they've also memo
almost made it taboo they've tried to
make it tab
to claim to see racism and they very
often say that seeing racism is the
racism or seeing racism is quote playing
the race card that's like the phrase
trump derangement syndrome these are
phrases meant to just shut down debate
they say on the right that the left
wants to shut down debate when you tell
anybody who has identified an act of
racism that the problem is then
mentioning it that is a form of shutting
down debate similarly there's this
phrase you're suffering from tds trump
derangement syndrome when somebody on
the internet will make a criticism of
Donald Trump Trump supporters will pop
up and they'll say you're suffering from
Trump derangement syndrome this is a way
to just shut down the debate you're
disqualifying the person making the
criticism as just being blinded by
hatred of Trump and being unable to
speak coherently what what you're
actually doing is you're shutting down
the person and not even having to defend
against the claims that's the same type
of thing that we see with oh you've
identified racism you're the person who
is actually racist she is still an
election official in Mississippi one of
the world leaders most prominently
denying the reality of corona virus has
been Brazilian president Geyer balsan ro
he has now tested positive for a corona
virus now he's 65 years old he has
trivialized the pandemic he would show
up places either without a mask or
wearing a mask incorrectly in terms of
total cases in Brazil now they are
second in the you in the world behind
the United States in terms of total
deaths Brazil is now second in the world
behind the United States in terms of per
capita they are also just below the
United States in both cases and deaths
and junior Boston ro was bragging in
March that if he were to get the virus
he would quickly fight it off and
recover because he has a history of
being an athlete he then kept going to
large events and to gatherings without
wearing a mask or again wearing it
incorrectly after announcing that he had
tested positive to reporters
yesterday he stepped back and took off
the mask and said look at my face
I feel fine he was also recently with a
bunch of his top cabinet members
everybody was not wearing a mask now I
got messages from people saying you know
David this could be the best thing that
happens to Brazil because this is going
to change both scenarios view of
coronavirus because he got it himself I
think you're very very wrong especially
if he fights it off he is going to be
reinvigorated about how this is really
no big deal and you know statistically
he's probably going to be fine because
again most people do not get very sick
even 65 year olds who are generally
healthy do not get very sick here in
Massachusetts I believe the average age
of death from coronavirus is like 82 or
something like that so in all likelihood
a relatively healthy 65 year old is
going to be fine and if he is and he
fights it off it will actually foment
him further downplaying it with you know
see I told you so it wasn't really
serious if he were to get really sick
it might change his view but this guy
seems so off-the-wall nuts and
disconnected from reality that it might
still not make a difference and when I
was looking online at the comments about
this you know a lot of people wishing
him harm that is never my take I don't
wish harm on anybody I'm recognizing the
propaganda value of this and he even
posted a video yesterday of himself
taking a pill which he claimed was
hydroxychloroquine he was laughing in
the video talking about how great he
feels and how the medication is
certainly working well and blah blah
blah it's all wacky propaganda I mean he
truly seems to have some kind of he has
an unusual personality I don't want to
diagnose anything but it's an unusual
personality now the other thing about
the more prominent people who get
coronavirus is it's believed or let me
put it a different way there's
speculation that when a prominent person
gets coronavirus they are immediately
getting access to antibody treatments
when we've seen the success rate of
these antibody treatments where you take
convalescent plasma from people
recovered and have antibodies and you
transfuse it into a sick person the
reports I've seen so far are that that
is very very effective and there's
speculation I don't want to say anything
other than there's speculation that when
a prominent or wealthy person gets the
virus they get access to that treatment
which is not widely available because of
the limitations you have to harvest
collect plasma from people who have
recovered and that also may be
increasing the success in fighting off
the virus for prominent or wealthy
people it's mere speculation that's the
latest with the Brazilian President Jo
balsan ara we have a voicemail number
that number is two one nine two david p
you know the claims about donald trump
paying someone to take his SATs have
raised questions about my SATs take a
listen to this david this is dave from
california yeah I have a question
Neary Trump said that the President had
somebody else take the SATs for him
right
my question is David did you take your
own SATs yeah by listen if I paid
someone to take my SATs I would have
come away with a better score it's kind
of a sad it's not a sad story but just
sort of a story of like being an
immigrant family because my family came
to the United States when I was five my
parents never went through the college
admissions process in the US my mom
ultimately went to graduate school here
but that's a very very different process
and that was after that that was much
later anyway and so I didn't know
anything about how do you prepare for
the SATs SAT prep materials SAT prep
classes or any of it so I had no
preparation and I just showed up and
took it and I did fine enough I got a
twelve ninety back when it was out of
1600 I believe now it's out of 2400 but
you know I I later learned about other
people who were doing prep classes they
had tutors they took the tests multiple
times for me I just showed up and took
it once and that was it and it was
fortunately good enough to get me into
the University of Massachusetts in
Amherst Massachusetts even applying for
school I had was just filling out
application
I didn't understand you know you can
request an interview and this increases
your chances of getting in there's
something called a common application I
filled out individual applications for
every school even though many of them
were on the I just had no idea but in
any case yes I took my own SATs
I also took my own GMAT when I took that
to get into grad school nothing and
again had I treated I would have gotten
myself a better score thank you
oh we have a great bonus show for you
today we're going to talk about how the
u.s. is reportedly considering banning
tick tock and some other Chinese media
we will talk about Texas is now ready to
resume executions after delaying some
during the corona virus pandemic and New
Jersey will now require outdoor masks
outdoor masks all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show reminder
about next Tuesday Tuesday night at 8
p.m. Eastern we will have the 3rd ever
David Pakman show chess tournament I
will be playing last tournament in June
we had 732 players I hope to do better
than that this time you can sign up now
for free for the tournament at david
pakman.com slash chess we also on the
same day will be doing a 1-day
membership special meant to dig us out
of a 300 member hole created earlier
this month and you can be notified about
this membership special very simply by
getting onto our mailing list at david
pakman.com you go to david pakman.com
top right of the website you will see a
place where you can type in your email
address get on the mailing list tuesday
midday you will get an email with a very
powerful explosive coupon code that will
get grant you an extraordinary discount
off of a membership and then hopefully
that night as a new member you'll play
in our chess tournament again which you
can register for it david pakman.com
slash chess I will see you in mere
moments on today's bonus show or
otherwise tomorrow
you